commenting on our site is completely
open so we don't even require
registration we thought about it but
lawyers are very paranoid about
confidentiality and if they're going to
be commenting on an item about their law
firm they don't want to provide any
information about their name or their
email or anything so it's completely
open and a lot of times people can say
that they are someone that they are
necessarily in the comments so people
might say oh well I'm a partner at a law
firm and perhaps they are not maybe
they're just a 1l in law school so it is
a little bit of an anarchic environment
which i think is what makes it a little
bit fun and they develop their own memes
and their own inside jokes it there are
some time as times when you wish that
there was a better signal-to-noise ratio
because sometimes the random comments
drown out the substantive ones but for
the most part I think the comments are
actually quite helpful and I think that
we get a much higher proportion or
number of comments compared to our other
main competitors and I think that is an
advantage for us it can also be a
headache because people might view the
site as if you judge the site based on
the commenters as opposed to the
material that we are the we the editors
are generating you might think that it
was written by particularly Juve on
juvenile people when really the content
that we put out under our own bylines is
rather professional it's just I mean it
has attitude but we are M you know we
are we do this full time this is a
professional operation but the
commenters can be quite rowdy
we do moderate comments on above the law
with some regularity usually for the
typical reasons something is offensive
something really offensive because we we
do believe in free speech but if
something is just really horribly
offensive we will moderate that if
something is potentially defamatory we
might moderate that but we get so many
comments and we don't have active
real-time moderation it tends to be more
of a notice and takedown kind of
approach a little bit like what YouTube
uses with respect to copyrighted videos
if someone has a problem with a comment
they should email us tips at above the
law calm and tell us this comment
comment number 53 on this post is
inappropriate can you please remove it
because we don't have time to on some
posts we get one post we did yesterday
or two days ago has 500 comments on it
we don't have time to read all 500 of
them we're too busy writing the next
post because one thing about blogging is
you have to continually be feeding the
beast every 30 minutes every hour people
want to see new content up
I am generally a fan of section 230
which is the law that makes website
operators essentially legally immune
from liability for comments posted by
third parties because I think it helps
foster free speech on the internet when
a website operator doesn't have to be
worried about getting in trouble because
of something that someone else posted it
would almost be like holding it in a way
I almost see the internet or a site like
ours as a wall and people will write
things on it and sometimes people will
write things that are intelligent and
substantive and sometimes people will
write things that are graffiti and I
don't think necessarily we should be
held liable for things that people write
that are inappropriate especially when
we do moderate them we will we do
moderate then there's this argument that
well because you moderate should you
lose your section 230 immunity the case
law says no just because you make a good
faith effort to remove the really bad
stuff doesn't mean you can be held
liable for the stuff that you leave up
but it's a definitely a tricky issue